what if you delivered an iPhone 15 to
1875 after you arve track down Alexander
Gran Bell and show him this absolute
Marvel of modern engineering he'll be
shocked by the wireless nature of the
device but also its ability to do so
much besides phone calls he won't
understand the concept of Wi-Fi
obviously but explain this to him and
leave the iPhone with him before you
leave he'll explore the technology
privately and never share it with anyone
but before he dies he'll pass it on to
his daughter Elsie Elsie will share the
iPhone with the US Government after
World War II breaks out which will lead
to the development of a top secret
Wireless communication system the
government will use it to defeat Germany
by 1941 the information will become
mainstream and the world will be fully
connected to Modern smartphones by the
1960s